notre invité qui nous a rejoint alain
corvez ce conseiller en stratégie
internationale à l'accord avec bonjour
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
vous êtes dans nos plateaux de caumartin
joe biden qui qui concluent donc son
opération séduction en europe avec cette
rencontre au sommet à genève
quel regard portez vous sur ce sommet
américano-russe tout d'abord je
reprendrai votre expression son opel
opération de séduction de baden en
europe il ya longtemps qu'elle est
entreprise par ses prédécesseurs et et
par son administration
l'europe est complètement séduite par
les états unis et nous sommes dans un
atlantisme sans défaut donc il n'y a pas
d'opération séduction il ya une
opération de recherche et les rangs pour
faire face aux menaces des etats-unis
dans le monde c'est-à-dire menace créée
ou décrétées par les états unis russie
et chine
alors concernant ce sommet on a dit tous
les dossiers qui fait qu'ils allaient
être abordées
mais les points de divergence sont
connus depuis longtemps et le
les points de convergence il y en a
relativement peu sur le climat peut-être
d'y tomber pourquoi pas mais le en
réalité je ne pense pas qu'au cours de
cet échange entre les deux présidents
américain et russe
on va découvrir ddd possibilité de
négociations sur les points principaux
puisque le président byden est arrivé en
europe pour resserrer les liens de ses
alliés et en disant nous allons être de
plus en plus ferme vis-à-vis des ennemis
des etats-unis il a pas d'histoire comme
ça bien sûr mais se traduit en termes
concrets nous allons être de plus en
plus ferme
nous occidentaux c'est à dire l'amérique
dirigeants ses alliés européens et 10 à
vis des menaces que sont la chine et la
russie
alors le sommet est une bonne chose
ah mais déjà vous voyez le
l'administration américaine a refusé une
conférence de presse commune comme il y
en a habituellement après les laisse
merdre chef d'état sans doute
une un certain malaise existe dans
l'administration américaine pour dire il
ya vraiment pas d'entendre possible avec
la russie je ne sais pas mais c'est en
tout cas c'est pas un bon signe que
l'administration américaine n'est pas
voulu à d'un sommet en commun d'une
conférence de presse commune
on sait que joe biden voix en vadimir
poutine un adversaire redoutable
mais finalement lequel est le plus
redoutable des deux selon vous mais
écoutez il n'y a pas que les personnages
il ya les intérêts et il ya les nations
qui sont derrière byden et derrière
poutine et je ne pense pas qu'un autre
président russe mènerait une politique
très différente peut-être avec moins de
fermeté ou moins de dextérité mais en
tout cas les intérêts de la russie ils
sont connus et du côté américain c'est
la même chose
là il ya des différences plus importante
puisqu'on avait vu que tu voulais
prendre en compte le fait que nous
entrions d'un monde multipolaire et
qu'il fallait discuter avec les
partenaires étrangers et dans
partenaires il comprenait russie chine
et au tout en étant très ferme en
particulier vis-à-vis de la chine
mais aujourd'hui le leu leu saut même je
pense de genève
marc là le caractère figé de cette
opposition fondamentale entre la
civilisation occidentale si tant est
qu'on puisse encore l'appeler du de
selon la civilisation en tout cas de
l'alliance atlantique dirigée par les
etats-unis face au reste du monde
or le reste du monde et maintenant le la
partie la plus importante de la planète
mais trois quarts de la planète sont le
reste du monde l'occident n'est qu'un
petit quart de cette planète et le jeu
revient là dessus de simple avaient
compris et c'est pour ça qu'il voulait
engager des états unis dans une
compréhension de cette réalité qui est
que la suprématie américaine totale sur
le monde est terminée et qu'il fallait
donc adapter la diplomatie américaine et
la stratégie américaine d'une manière
générale et la défense américaine d'une
manière générale il y a une puissance
nucléaire très puissante très très
grande qui est la russie à la chine qui
montrent également dans le domaine de la
défense nucléaire et il ya d'autres pays
la suprématie américaine est maintenant
arrêter elle s'est manifestée pendant
dix ans à l'écroulement de l'urss
mais depuis déjà une dizaine d'années le
phénomène de multipolarisation du monde
ce ne fait que s'amplifier
alors il ya énormément de dossiers sur
lesquels les deux hommes n'arrivent pas
à s'entendre le plus brûlant si je puis
dire de ces dossiers et lequel sur vous
je pense que celle ukraine
et pourtant je devrais plus le dossier
qui pourrait s'il n'y avait pas
s'il y avait de la modération des deux
côtés et je pense qu'il y en a du côté
russe et qu'il n'y en a pas du côté
américain sur ce dossier on a vu comment
s'est passée la révolution de 2014 avec
les services secrets américains à la
manoeuvre pour renverser un gouvernement
qui n'avaient pas le plaisir de plaire à
washington
donc le dossier ukrainien est un dossier
très sensible et pourtant c'est un sens
à un dossier sur lequel ils pourraient
s'entendre
la russie n'a pas du tout intérêt à
faire la guerre à l'ukraine et n'a pas
du tout l'intention de s'emparer de
l'ukraine simplement ce qu'elle veut
c'est que les populations russophile et
russophone qui sont dans l'est de
l'ukraine soit considérée et elle droit
et à une certaine autonomie mais non pas
indépendance le le régime de
de la constitution ukrainienne et est un
régime fédéral mais qui doit être
accentué et permettre à aux provinces de
donetsk lougansk de devenir de d'avoir
le droit de se gérer de la façon dont il
le chouette tout en restant dans
l'intégrité territoriale de la russie de
la de l'ukraine et bien sûr la crimée et
apparaît les russes pour les russes
définitivement et là on peut pas on peut
pas négocier là dessus mais sur le
donbass je pense qu'il ya des
négociations possibles car l'intérêt de
la russie chez d'avoir une province
d'ukraine qui soit partie intégrante de
l'ukraine et qui
dépendent de kiev mais qu'il lui soit
plutôt favorable et il la russie n'a
aucune intention de s'emparer d'une
basse je pense que c'est ce que la
dîmière poutine pour a expliqué à
bayonne
si toutefois il donne ne s'est pas déjà
alors joe biden qui a également déclaré
après son entretien avec avec ses alliés
notant qu'il allait signifier à vladimir
poutine
ces lignes rouges est-ce que vous pensez
que la lumière poutine pourrait
également voilà signifier lui aussi
quelques lignes rouges at the maiden va
écouter les lignes rouges je pense que
de part et d'autre tout le monde les
connaît simplement parlé des droits de
l'homme concernant navalni et autres
navale nick est d'ailleurs à nos
opposants qui représente pas grand chose
en opposant politique qui représente pas
grand chose en russie
les lignes rouges je pense que des deux
côtés on les connaît parfaitement
mais je je je je ressens moi comme une
volonté du côté américain de ne pas
négocier de de rester un bloc atlantique
hostile à la russie et à la chine bien
sûr parce que en arrière plan il ya la
chine derrière tout ça alors que du côté
russe et même du côté chinois également
mais du côté russe
c'est très clair que
la diplomatie russe voulait mettre sur
la table les différents les différences
d'intérêt sur un certain nombre de
sujets mais négociée est trouvée parce
qu'il faut bien
à moins de faire la guerre il faut bien
trouver des terrains d'entente entre des
opinions différentes sur des sujets que
ce soit l'ukraine la syrie ou ailleurs à
cet égard d'ailleurs la syrie est un est
un point très important parce que
l'intervention russe de 2015 a
complètement transformé la situation est
aujourd'hui en syrie tout le monde
reconnaît que c'est la russie qui est le
principal décideur de la suite
alors voyez il ya des ya des points où
de part et d'autre on pourrait
s'entendre faire des avancées admettre
que l'autre à ea est en position de
force sur tel à tel endroit ou sur tel
point et en tirer des conclusions mais
je sens en tout cas dans les
déclarations depuis que le président
byden à débarquer en europe
les déclarations sont des déclarations a
priori hostile
en dix ans on vient pas pour négocier on
va définir des lignes rouges à la russie
il y à une autre politique qui
consisterait à dire on va discuter avec
l'art ici pour voir comment on peut
amener à baisser la tension sur des
points importants
l'ukraine l'afghanistan la russie
navalni ou autre
merci beaucoup en tout cas alain qu'en
baisse d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ce matin en direct donc de nos plateaux
havre caumartin je rappelle être
conseiller en stratégie internationale